joined by former England footballer
Luther Blissett who was the first black
player to score in an England shirt
hello to you thanks for joining us
really appreciate it
what did you make it mud ah thanks what
did you make about what happened last
night
it saddens me every time it happens and
unfortunately you get resigned to the
fact that this is going to happen at
certain places and you know they seem
not be very keen on doing anything about
it okay what can well we know what your
wafer should be doing about it we know
what they have got in place to try to do
something about it what can inland do to
try to start to change the way other
nations around the world treat England
players I think what what needs to
happen is is that all the players should
be briefed if this sort of incidents
ever happened you know then they beat
the referee and the referee has actually
got the power who make Bavaria's they
and I announcement to this crowd to say
this needs to stop otherwise I will take
days off a bit and you can do that and
if it happens again using his power to
actually abandon the game so the
referees also need to take some
responsibilities in this to deal with
the situation and it doesn't always have
to fall on there on the shoulders of
players many years ago it was it
happened to mention computers of my own
my writing in Barcelona and you know he
walked off pitch and his own players
they've got it I'm back on it is very
important that the officials they
apparently there was a protocol in in
place already we've been agree that if
Bissell's officials should do this and
it's something they're not doing but at
the end of day if nothing happens on the
day then I think UEFA should in my
opinion and this would it's not about
sending out a mess showing that action
will be taken they should actually bro
Montenegro out of the out of the
competition from here on in and it's
quite ironic really when they've
actually got Negro in a name of their
country do you think that the penalty
are strong enough from what you're
saying I'm guessing you're saying no no
no that's not I mean that they go with
financial you know punishments for these
countries and these offenders of this
sort of thing and they play the game
behind closed doors it should not even
get to that they should just get thrown
out and competition so to do that that
would that would show that it is totally
not behave in that manner and they need
to do more themselves pressure impact
does this have on players when they find
themselves abused in this way on the
pitch it's an awful thing because you're
out there doing your job and any one of
us if you get abused in any way when
you're out doing your day you yeah it's
not a very pleasant place and it's not
something you look forward to go into I
don't know any footballers that don't
enjoy going out of playing football
that's but they're in the game dude and
we've be faced with this on a regular
basis when you travel abroad playing
these games it's not very nice because
it does take away that real excitement
and that and that loss about the job
that you do because we're very
privileged and their talent is enabled
them to be going all over the world and
doing this and they need to be protected
in the right way by two authorities
because they are the one time that are
let in electing the players down in that
respect we worked on it in this country
and we have made great strides but we
still have a way to go but the biggest
difference is we acknowledge there is a
problem I mentioned this morning on a
program I was doing that if they were to
just throw these countries out someone
said to me then it would punish players
how many of the players or officials
from that country have come out and said
they find a disgrace both of that has
happened all I've heard is their their
communication or press often as we're
trying to do everything they could to
get everybody away from saying anything
about the fact that this racism thing
actually happened so it proves that
they're in denial and the only way to
bring these people reality is to make
them suffering the most in a most
strongest way kick them out of
competition and they lose out
financially in so many ways
we must not forget after the I saw
incident British clubs were banned from
playing in Europe for I think five years
or whatever it was
why Cannot they do this book country or
something which in my you know which is
just as bad but doing this sort of thing
to single somebody out because of their
color or their religion or whatever it
is totally wrong you say we have made
great strides and yet we are having this
conversation you know it's many years
later from when you were subject to
abuse I'm sure on more than one occasion
what does the FA need to do surely that
the FA as an organisation needs to speak
out more loudly yes they do I think all
all organisations involved in supporting
all need to stand up and say this is not
acceptable fines that you're you're
handing out is not right and doing games
behind closed doors is not right you
have to take a very strong stance with
these these sort of things now and the
education will come but to stir them and
to drop them into the dealing with the
education you have to do something which
is which really shocks them and for me
now it got abandoned the the FA need to
do more on the I think informing the
players of what their rights are what
the what the criteria is for them if
this happened in a game and if this is
drummed into the plays and the players
know it every time they walk into a ball
pit for an international that they just
need go to the officials and say we've
you know we've been abused and you need
to do something about it and then the
steps can be taken but until this
happens then what's left for the or the
England manager but Gareth Southgate who
round his players up and take them off
the pitch I don't think that is the
right thing for for him to be doing not
his place to be doing that sort of thing
that should be done by people that are
the administrators of the game and the
worldwide game for sefa and UEFA are
culpable in this they pretty much saying
that racism doesn't exist but we all
know it does as Eric was in England has
done and I think this brexit thing
hasn't helped which is what I think has
sparked a lot of this incidence that
we're having now in England again
because of that
I can see getting lots of notifications
on your computer is you're chatting to
his peoples you know I can see you on
the sky I know I know
tell me about the picture behind you
that one oh that was a picture from when
I had my testimony many years ago there
was a local art and he he painted that
actually so and I still got it up on the
wall because there it reminds me of my
younger days when I was bitten Alf being
very strong and love doing what I do it
now I've just got a think and dream
about it
we're shorts really that short back then
they were they weren't in fact I think
he made those longer